les réfugiés sont souvent très incompris
et il était donc important pour moi que les
gens sachent vraiment qui ils sont en tant que
personnes
[Musique]
mon nom était Marshalene rappelé en
guimauve, vous savez comme une blague parce qu'elle
était juste la femme la plus douce
du monde
[Musique  ]
[Musique] il
y a une personne qui a compris certaines
choses sur le monde dans l'histoire de
ce pays et qui a évidemment changé dans ma
vie.
[Musique]
J'ai pris un engagement aussi et je suis sûr que
je travaillerai avec elle pour le reste  de ma
vie parce qu'ils sont si extraordinaires
et et et devraient avoir davantage une voix
publiquement
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
ma vie quotidienne, c'est être à la maison avec mes
enfants et ce n'est pas le cas, il y a très peu de
division entre ça et la compréhension
ce qui se passe dans le monde parce que
comprendre ce qui se passe, le monde est ce qui
fait de moi une meilleure personne, un meilleur
parent et c'est mon objectif
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique] les
petits enfants ont demandé ce qu'ils ont vu et
ils ont décrit les parties du corps séparées  et
brûlé des gens en train de démonter un
poulet qui est une petite fille de neuf ans
[Musique]
très très reconnaissante d'avoir eu l'
opportunité de pouvoir faire le
choix que j'ai fait et et très heureuse que
d'autres femmes sachent qu'elles l'ont fait
ce choix
[Musique]
nous devons changer les attitudes à l'égard de la
violence sexuelle et mettre fin à l'impunité pour ces
crimes,
la seule réponse est de mettre fin aux conflits qui
forcent les gens à fuir leurs foyers et
que tous les gouvernements assument leurs
responsabilités
[Musique]